c'est comme citoyen libre indépendant
mais engagée que c'est présenté arnaud
montebourg pour cette treizième
ascension du mont beuvray
l'ancien député de saône-et-loire a
soigné son retour sur la scène politique
lui conférant un caractère très
solennelle les dizaines de médias sont
présents mais lui ne dit pas un mot aux
journalistes pendant toute la montée
réservant ces annonces pour son discours
très critique sur l'état actuel du pays
il a fustigé le système politique
devenue selon lui les grandes machines à
trahir
avant de lancer un appel au peuple je
vous propose de bâtir dans les mois qui
viennent un grand projet alternatif pour
le pays
alternatif aux appareils politiques et
or leur censure et audacieux dans
l'invention de notre futur alternatif à
la pensée unique qui a fusionné la
droite et la gauche et créatif dans la
recherche de solutions nouvelles
alternatif a l'expérience de ce qui ne
marche pas et efficace dans la recherche
de résultats pour les français pour le
pays
arnaud montebourg est un projet innovant
pour réconcilier la france qui va bien
et la france qui va mal
un projet avec des valeurs de gauche des
valeurs qu'il a longuement rappelé en se
référant à vingt-quatre personnalités
jaurès roosevelt mitterrand voltaire
mendès france et même simone veil ou le
cas de françois tant qu'on n'a pas
entendu parler comme ça enfin la
retrouver la gauche pas encore candidat
mais déjà candidat pour bâtir un projet
avec les français c'est ce chemin
qu'arnaud montebourg a validé en
ironisant sur les très nombreux
candidats déclarés mais sans projet les
responsables politiques veulent réformer
la société je proposerai d'abord que la
société réforme le système politique et
les responsables politiques
je trouve qu'il ne s'est pas présenté
comme un homme l'homme providentiel mais
comme loeb qui veut travailler avec la
société civile
c'est l'appel au travail et je crois
véritablement que beaucoup de français
en ont un petit peu ras-le-bol de cette
de ces gens qui verrait virevoltent dans
les médias qui nous dit voilà je vais
écouter jeanne d'arc que j'ai des idées
parce que j'ai entendu jeanne d'arc
espace à un projet politique un projet
sur politique surtout à gauche ça n'a
jamais été sa primaire ou par nous même
bourg a fait un pas de plus aujourd'hui
vers une candidature qui pourrait
intervenir à la fin de l'été pourquoi
pas à la fête de la rose de
frangy-en-bresse